[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that men on Batman wellin you know
oftentimes it linked about other stuff
welcome to fat man Batman Kevin Smith I
am mark Barnard oh we got so much to
talk about we are in London right now at
the London Film and Comic Con put your
hands together so the audience at home
knows you were reel to reel to reel
thanks for being here this is we will
kick off the show with what I think is
breaking [ __ ] news I don't know that
I mean it's all over the the Internet so
you know it's not like I'm breaking it
myself no you don't know breaking it to
you guys you don't have a guy who knows
a guy who knows a thing I have a opened
my phone and read this hot pie from Game
of Thrones uh-huh and I opened my his
name is Ben hockey he's the kid that
plays hot pie okay
best name ever go in real life has
opened a bakery here in London what's
just like his character and he makes
direwolf bread just like he gave to arya
and that bakery is called tell you know
nothing John Doe now it says it's a
delivery only bakery so what does that
mean like you can't go in I'm pretty
sure we could go in let's [ __ ] go
show up and just like wait let us in its
delivery only though that's like you're
not allowed to walk in do you think
that's because like everyone will be
like hot and [ __ ] he's like I can't get
any baking done it's all these
underwears he's getting thrown at him
you can't people just wanna [ __ ] hot pie
yeah I winds it on Twitter last week
after the episode played if I said I
would not be surprised if hot pie made
it to the Iron Throne cuz he was sitting
there gone I'm a survivor and you just
know that means next week you're gonna
see hot pies head on a [ __ ] stick or
something like that
somebody serving hot pie hot pies
it's about browning the butter as he
told us what news have you uncovered
here comic-con or what have you been
doing since you've been here at
comic-con uh you came over as yourself
like well no no I came over as Billy Dee
Williams but nobody would buy that
you're far shorter and less cool than
Billy dude like where's your cape it's
sorted in the sack
you see I'm getting British isms down
what what is it what what you they
brought you over as a standalone guy
like mark barnard from yeah comic books
they brought me out they brought me lose
me first and then like hey you you
you're a guy who writes comic books and
maybe work on our TV show do you want to
come into a convention I said yes and
then they were like oh hey Kevin is
coming also I said amazing and then it
became a thing and then it was like
surprise people becoming up to me at the
signings and stuff and like I met Mark
Bernardino's like I [ __ ] work with
them you're not impressing me put your
dick away but you you're legit like
personality legit personality it's
[ __ ] weird isn't it
mom I never said there'd be days like
this my mom too was just like you're
doing a show tomorrow I said yeah I'm
doing fat man I'm back with Mark Barnard
and she goes was that like I was like
marks like in a really good story guy
can break
story down insanely well and blah blah
blah and you know my mom's just glazing
over she's because all she sees is like
oh tiger you know my boy talks I don't
care what he talks about you know but
then I said like I'm you know mark his
wife went to middle town south which is
like very near where I went to high
school at Henry Hudson in Highlands in
New Jersey and it was a name that my mom
instantly snapped her into the
conversation like what tell me more
about this woman yeah like oh my god we
must know her I'm like we didn't know
anybody what's a middle tense up but it
put her so close to the house it made
you feel like [ __ ] family
so not only a bit of a degree of
celebrity and [ __ ] but you're also a
degree of family in our house well I
mean I like you you tend to love her I
feel like I've been a part of your
family for a while
yeah like a tender who have you seen
since you've been here the other day I
was in the stairwell
and who was it walked by Oh is Natalie
Dormer and I was like oh [ __ ] man like
after she walked past you know she's
like hello I said hey I don't I wanted
to be like oh [ __ ] it and I said it to
the people I was with I was like that's
amble in from the tutors and they looked
at me and they're like and Game of
Thrones I was again I [ __ ] to
Margaery but [ __ ] that was amber I
remember watching the tutors and her
death episode was [ __ ] amazing and I
wrote to my agents my endeavour at the
time and I said hey man
does anybody rep this girl just can I
want to send her an email go on like
that [ __ ] the death of Anne Boleyn
was amazing like I was a big Thomas More
fan so technically I should be rooting
for the death of Anne Boleyn and stuff
but she made the character so human and
lovable that like when Henry killed her
off like I've I lost it I was real
emotional my wife came in she's like
what happened did your mother die and I
was like no Anne Boleyn did you know
she's like who's that a distant aunt and
I'm like no she's history you know so I
saw her and then you know they were like
you know she was also than this this
she's in Captain America too and then
somebody was like she was in Hunger
Games you [ __ ] idiot and I was like I
just like the tutors all right Bob who
else I see I told them last night we did
a show SModcast I said I saw I was in
the hallway and [ __ ] I saw this
insanely good Terence Stamp cosplayer I
was like that's the best [ __ ] Terence
Stamp cosplayer I've seen in my life and
they were like that's Terence Stamp
and I was think he's here like guys
everyone's kneeling before Zod and [ __ ]
like that people taking pictures and
kneeling in front of him mache I saw
yesterday the green room is a [ __ ]
bizarre place to be but I was standing
there and I saw somebody walk like kind
of gingerly up to meet John Cleese he
was in the green he was in the green
room and it was Benedict Cumberbatch who
was like I just I've always wanted to
meet you I I wish my mom was here to see
me meet you and it was adorable it would
have been so much better if Cleese was
like and you are
yeah Cleese was here man he said it was
like his first signing yeah I was I was
set up yesterday next to John
rhys-davies yeah Salah and Gimli yeah
and he's gonna do I was tweeting about
this last night
he's like mid-80s maybe he was in a bad
playing accident years ago and smashed a
leg there to reconstruct it so one leg
is shorter than the other so he's
standing next to me and anytime somebody
with a wheelchair would pull up to the
thing he would stand up walk around to
go and shake the person's hand oh my god
you could tell like just his back is
screaming all the time utter class yeah
three-piece suit also like blue
pinstripes have a row like top notch
well that's overdoing it well but he
would walk around they would shake their
hand he walk back and every time he
would pass me behind you clapped me on
the shoulders is you handsome devil if
only every time in class you hit you
with like a classic [ __ ] line or is
like bad dates
vanilluxe are you the monarch of the sea
yes oh my friends I'm so pleased you're
not dead who else have you seen
I saw the cast of iron fist and kept my
mouth shut
[Applause]
don't come to England and pick fight
such an American thing to do I held my
tongue but inside you were screaming
going I've got an opinion I have fought
who did I see I saw Alan Tudyk I was
signing next to him today and everybody
kept coming up to the table I kept going
it's a [ __ ] robot and they're like
what but I was trying to explain it was
like he's in a zillion things but I was
referring to like rogue one so I kept
building up to because I essentially
just could not remember the robot's name
so it wasn't like c-3po it doesn't roll
off the tongue and I was like ky k9 what
the [ __ ] so I kept saying like he's the
he's the robot and somebody was like
Kate what does the k2 is to us he was k2
s oh and I was like that's the [ __ ]
name now and looks at me like that [ __ ]
and then we had people get engaged in
front of us I saw the two people in the
wheelchair
[Applause]
so lovely it's [ __ ] an incredible
moment and like ten people after you
somebody got up to the table and like
did somebody just get married here and I
was like well no but they're on their
way and [ __ ] and they looked relieved
like thank God I didn't miss anything or
something but it was a beautiful
beautiful moment when you guys gonna
tied a knot don't know yet
get on the [ __ ] answer man move it
I met a alicia witt to know who alicia
witt is yeah she's uh she was I mean she
recently she was in walking she's
walking dead she was on justified I know
her from fun a movie called funny she
did with Renee Humphries years ago I
know her from wait for my brother
Barry that's why she's in dude Dahlia
and dude often grown up and lovely and
her eyes are totally still blue are they
really that same cause she's a singer
right yeah she had a gig London she's
delightful
everybody's delightful cuz it's long
alyson hannigan and her husband and her
husband as well Alexis Denisof
and I just know names my job is to know
names I don't know it's been kind of
weird and wonderful like so you know I
saw it was I didn't see her like in
person or whatever but I was down in the
garage creepily smoking weed and so you
know you see everyone that goes to the
elevator I saw Pamela Anderson shut up
who looks like she literally was plucked
from the 90s and put here she hasn't
like aged at least from a distance and
she was and she was impeccably dressed
like stylish and for for this [ __ ]
fat [ __ ] to notice who has no sense
of hot creature whatsoever that says
something I was a goddamn it she's
[ __ ] stylish and [ __ ] I was gonna go
over me like teach me to dress
thought it might have weirded her out
though so didn't do it go for it man
you're in London I know right
I wanted to go talk to the guy who plays
Hodor so badly I did talk to him
yesterday
did you he's such a nice guy cuz he
walked in it was like Friday morning and
we both got that we both had flown in
from LA yeah just after doing San Diego
was that how you doing like I'm [ __ ]
wrecked I was just saying it me too I
was DJing and I was whoring all over the
blaze and you just sat there looked
alright let's go
stands up [ __ ] giant like hobbles
over to the door by Hodor did he hold it
yeah that's what I did I would fan out
big time it'd just be like Christ dude
you don't know how many times I
rewatched that episode is one of the
most heroic things ever seen depicted in
fiction it made me feel like less of a
human being and you're not even real I
mean you're real but the [ __ ]
character is not made me weep maybe call
my mother and tell her how much I loved
her and stuff like that so maybe I'll
have the moment maybe I'll just kind of
nut up and go over and be like hi I did
that to someone recently a tee Brian
she's on at Sarah and live in the States
and there's a sketch they do an SNL
called girlfriends talk show which I
[ __ ] in the door so she was a Comic Con
and I went over and I was like um my
name is Kevin I just wanna say I'm a
huge fan and she looked like she was
like oh oh thank you you know it was
like hi I'm Hitler and I'm a huge fan
she seemed a little like I don't know
what to do with that information being
that it's coming from you who's kind of
interesting so maybe it shied me away
from going up and being like oh my god
I'm a huge fan but I think I will before
the comments not do it I met Benedict
Wong right on who's a lovely guy how are
you fine say how's affinity war going
tell me everything I can't they'll kill
me well but you're so lovely they won't
kill you you're cuddly
you're my cuddly magic friend yeah it's
a who's who in that [ __ ] green room
we got news to get to we have a little
bit of news a bunch of news like broke
at San Diego and then they turned off
the new spigot but we have a teensy bit
Warwick Davis is going to be in the
untitled Han Solo movie because oh
really yeah it turns out you can't make
a Star Wars movie these days without
Warwick Davis in it but also that's a
[ __ ] will over you and it's been 30
years yeah we're on our yeah Wow
playing somebody short untitled short
person
maybe if him maybe he's smoked at the
end of the day start floating that might
happen that's big news that's too huge
seems to be having a good time taking
over that Han Solo movie he's kind of
taking a you know a [ __ ] situation where
everybody was like ill man they fired
these guys we all loved from the lego
movie in [ __ ] 21 Jump Street and
they're bringing in Ron Howard who you
know we all like and stuff but like
what's going on here what kind of games
being played and ultimately you just
can't just like Ron Howard he's kind of
a sweet guy and he keeps putting up real
fun Instagram posts he you know most
people if I was given that job I'd be
like [ __ ] man we're replacing somebody
and we're replacing people that people
like but he's a guy that was just like
well you know I'm here to do a job let's
do it it seems to be enjoying himself
while doing it they put up some post
today of him and the cinematographer
Bradford Young who was the DP on arrival
and Selma and it's okay we're just
making [ __ ] up as we go was basically
the internet post you guys are having so
much fun not spiraling in a debt spin
did you hear what the like ultimately
what was it that got the two other guys
[ __ ] can the the vibe that I've gotten
you know from both stuff that we've been
in the press and talking to people about
it it was that the movie began to
diverge from what Kathy Kennedy and
Lucasfilm wanted to be and the kind of
improv comedy that those guys wanted to
make and somewhere along the line it was
just this is not a Star Wars movie
anymore this is a comedy that you're
making up as you go and we have a plan
like it's it would be like trying to
make up a Marvel movie like you can't do
that they have they have a [ __ ] 20
year plan of how that's supposed to go
and you can't just be the dude it's like
I think they
you have a slumber party no it's we're
gonna fight ja my god I want to see that
version of the [ __ ] Star Wars movie
the infinity cuddle the yeah I guess the
notion of kind of jumping in and
ad-libbing a Star Wars movie probably
seems expensive as well too that like
you're burning through cash and stuff as
you doing multiples but at the idea at
scene at the same time it would have
been kind of cool to see a movie with a
sense of humor other like intentional
Cinzia more not like the Star Wars
Christmas special you know like the idea
where they were trying to make you laugh
instead yeah but I guess we're not gonna
see that very I mean I wonder how much
and nobody knows how much of their
original stuff will survive in the movie
because I can't imagine as a director is
a part of the Directors Guild it's gonna
be an interesting like how do you share
those credits yeah
how do you split them up especially if
they wind up reshooting a bunch of
things like how do you split the credits
or do you split the credits there's Ron
Howard just take a producing credit and
the original team gets their credit yeah
which is weird because everybody in the
world knows that Ron Howard will finish
this movie no it'd be weird yeah all
right we'll follow more on that later
what else Warner Brothers is reportedly
gonna mount a Best Picture Oscar
campaign for Wonder Woman I think that's
smart I mean that's not what I thought
when I saw the movie like boy this will
win an Oscar but like I think now
there's enough goodwill behind it and
it's broken enough Records where you
could definitely run it for some stuff
yeah and like the Oscars like to have
that's that's why they spend the
category to include up to ten nominees
they want two or three of them to be
movies people have seen hmm ever and not
just like tiny Croatian documentaries
about doll making and mine explosions
like it's like oh look a billion people
have seen this movie maybe they'll watch
the Oscars now good boy yeah and it's
really good like why the [ __ ] wouldn't
you do that they rarely try for comic
book movies like when something like
Deadpool gets an award people like oh
[ __ ] it did well thanks you know they
don't try they don't run it their
campaign it yeah so to kind of set out
to do it you know if you're gonna try
with any comic book movie that would
seem like the one to go with I
they Warner Brothers was a three years
ago they had a decision between running
Mad Max fury road for Best Picture or
the Johnny Depp Black Mass movie which
they thought was going to be there like
here's our Oscar thing we're gonna get
all the gold for this and so they
siphoned all of their resources away
from fury road which then got nine
nominations and won seven Oscars but I
think they were burned by that a little
bit and black masks got nothing because
it was only so-so
so I think this time around the like
everybody loves this movie we think it's
good let's actually put some resources
behind it maybe we can get it there
where'd you see fury road on the road to
Valhalla where did you see fury road I
want to see it in Buffalo New York
because that's what you do I was I was
out doing a gig like stand-up gig and I
was in Buffalo
my friend Malcolm Ingram lives in
Toronto which is kind of directly above
you know if it's a couple hours drive
but Malcolm is a bear in the gay
community that's a dude that looks like
me and Fox dudes that look like Jason
Mewes I guess like Jay and Silent Bob
would be a bear twink couple or as
Malcolm would point out he's just like
you know you know he's like I'm a bear
he told me one day just he's such a
I love Malcolm to death he's my friend
that's very blow hardy and [ __ ] like
that he's the guy that it's like we came
out of Batman V Superman and I was like
what you think he's like it's a
cinematic abortion a where you're like
rein it in [ __ ] you know so he's
very that guy so he for years Jason
Mewes would like you know is the 90s so
he would insist that Malcolm was gay
because he saw Malcolm eita Cabasa once
and he was like I know he's [ __ ] gay
you know and he telling Malcolm you're
gay and Malcolm's like stop it no I'm
not he's like yeah I've seen you eat
Cabasa
and she'll like that but is there an on
gateway to eat kielbasa this is gonna
dice it up into tiny cubes throw it in
your mouth
that's a serial killer that's not a
street
so he he was one day called me up and he
was like I'm I just want to tell you I'm
a bear and I was like what he's like I'm
a bear I'm a gay man I'm a bear and I
was like oh oh right on I I we always
thought but we didn't know and I told
Jason Mewes and Jason goes I did it to
him I was like what do you mean he's
like I kept saying he was gay and he
just went for it so Malcolm you know is
the one he was explaining the bear
community to me he was like what's it
like he's like you [ __ ] love it he's
going because dudes like us finally
[ __ ] come out on top and I mean that
literally
he's like I bet you never [ __ ] take
your shirt off during sex I was like I
don't take my [ __ ] shirt off in the
shower why would I take it off during
sex what if my wife sees my tits are
bigger than hers and [ __ ] and he goes in
the gay community man when you're in the
bear community you [ __ ] take all the
clothes off the fattest part of the sex
and I was like how you just push your
tits together and get [ __ ] between
over something like that and he goes no
it's even worse I said what is it he
goes well [ __ ] like you know what
they love the fat you work it into the
sex so like there'll be a dude and he's
[ __ ] sucking my dick he's like and
then I'll pick up my gut and then I'll
gently put it on his head I said get
outta here cuz know what I [ __ ] love
it he's like I'll rub it back and forth
like I'm rubbing a bowling ball he's
like and then when I'm about to [ __ ] I
lift my gut up and when I come I drop it
on his [ __ ] hat and I said you don't
[ __ ] get punched for that and he goes
no we call it love
so Malcolm is my big bear friend and
Malcolm came down to Buffalo and I was
doing a gig and I you know the more I
had nothing to do I did a night full of
gigs two gigs and then the whole next
day nothing to do until at night to
morgan's so fury road was out and I was
like let's go check it out man and he's
a guy right but I don't want to eat the
movie snack someone a diet and I was
like I said we just won't get snacks
he's like I didn't say I didn't want to
eat I just don't eat the movie snacks I
was like what do you suggest he's like
let's go to the grocery store so he went
to the grocery store and just picked out
like [ __ ] as if we were shopping for the
house like he bought [ __ ] cheeses and
bought Cabasa as well
bought a paring knife to cut it with and
[ __ ] like that bought a bottle of wine
you know I bought some [ __ ] rice
krispie treats that was my big [ __ ]
purchase and [ __ ] she was having a
picnic
he bought a picnic basket he had it in a
[ __ ] bag brown paper bag we go to the
theater and stuff we buy our tickets and
we get inside we give our tickets to the
ticket kid Malcolm's carrying this
big-ass [ __ ] bag of a grocery bag
full of groceries and so the guy rips
the ticket and we walk past and you can
tell he's in a moral quandary and then
finally he's like excuse and I turned I
was I guess it was like I you you can't
bring food like real food into a movie
theater and I was like oh we're not
gonna eat it we just went grocery
shopping and it's hot outside so it's
cold in here so we just didn't want the
cheese to go bad so we're just putting
it under our seat and he goes okay and
so then we went to the theater and
literally unpacked a [ __ ] picnic
and [ __ ] worry like wine and cheese
and cutting it onto little crackers and
[ __ ] like that and that's how we watched
fury road all classy and [ __ ] like and
absolutely adored that movie like I was
I liked Mad Max and I liked the road
warrior when I was a kid they were part
of my childhood but not a seminal part
of it there were movies that I saw once
and appreciate it but wasn't a big cult
fan of but at that movie I [ __ ] loved
that movie made me a bigger fan of the
earlier two and even beyond thunderdome
which is really [ __ ] hard but it was
a wonderfully [ __ ] put together movie
by a guy who's 70 years old yes so it's
like you watch him - 70 year old man
makes fury road 35 year old man makes
yoga hosers you know it's like you can
see there's a no you're just you're
working up to it yeah one day I'll get
to fury road I'll never get to fury road
I'm not mad enough you know what I'm
saying I'm just too chill we can fix
that no so I can make you mad I'll
figure it out now let's you're casting
news all right so that's what's the next
thing on the list the next thing on the
list is the it trailer dropped and we
seem to be in the middle of sava yeah
yeah like a Stephen King Renaissance
like there's now five projects happening
Stephen King related within the next
year name them off and save the one you
know best for last
okay the mist currently on Spike they're
doing that show right now
like mr. Mercedes that says the Stephen
King yeah I don't know which one but it
is okay The Dark Tower yes that's coming
out very soon the states lose it the
trailer is pretty creepy it's yeah I'm
not gonna stay because I'm a [ __ ] and
then Castle Rock Castle Rock is a TV
show or a streaming show that's gonna be
on Amazon
it'll be on Hulu in the US and then
somewhere else internationally the
bruisers name on the show on the castle
rock show yeah JJ Abrams one of the
writers on the show me mark barnard and
writes on that show ladies gentlemen
good guys so not only are you doing news
about the Stephen King Renaissance you
are literally part of the Stephen King
Renaissance I am and I can plant like
false flag information and see which bad
sites pick it up it's like oh no it's a
time travel story
oh no it's absolutely about penny wise
before he was penny wise when he was
just a boy before he was a demon class
that what it's about
yeah no yeah that's what when I first
heard of that show it's like oh my god
it's gonna be like The Avengers of the
Stephen King universe like [ __ ]
Christine's gonna go screeching up onto
the lawn of the Overlook Hotel and
[ __ ] Cujo is gonna pop out of the
card ship I mean season two don't give
it away this is the cat but with Cujo
what is the what is the word on the ax
trailer of those creepy this really
looks creepy as [ __ ] and the the movie
has been a little bit naughty was a
controversial but they lost their first
director cary fukunaga was gonna be the
director the dude who did true detective
and I think they just had the infamous
Hollywood creative differences and it
just didn't work out and they got this
guy that I've never heard of before and
still don't know his name rich do you
know his name [ __ ] come on man yet one
job you know the guy directed it and it
looks amazing
it looks creepy as hell you know and and
horror is among many things it's it's a
movie about codes and it's a it's a
genre about you know tipping things with
color and and foreshadowing and watching
even in the trailer the way they use the
color red the were--it that get just
pops up it's the the V on the beach
castle that they've been written losers
and turn into lovers there's there's
just little swatches of red which of
course is the red balloon that penny
wise used to lure you into the sewer it
looks amazing and it shouldn't be god
it's a remake of it it shouldn't look
good it's got one of those stranger
things
- wolf oh yeah and the dude who plays
penny wise bill skarsgård is in Castle
Rock also oh yeah who is it what are the
skarsgård boys there's 19 of them I
think they they breed them like
Hemsworth's over there see he's related
to the just telling he's Stella's kid
and Alexander the vampire that [ __ ]
guy is hot I mean it's like he's there's
there's a Norwegian tennis pro factory
that they just keep churning out these
lanky tall blond Adonis's and frankly
it's annoying yeah like I would like
less of them in the world because in
America they turn out [ __ ] like this hey
you do we are Americans ladies and
gentlemen but we are over here of course
on England's grand shores and there's a
website here that I've been reading for
years and and as a stellar reputation
and a good dude that run runs a who I've
been emailing with for years so we
figured since we're here I guarantee you
he knows some [ __ ] going on in the world
of comics that we don't in the world of
the con so welcome to the stage from
bleeding cool calm rich Johnston
everybody there's no chairs right there
how are you sir very well what's the
word man give us some gossip oh what a
good one would be a Dan Fogler you know
the guy from sick be somebody fine
though number one he's also starting a
whole new line of comic books he writes
and draws comics he's doing somewhat new
stuff Moon Lake is amazing for heavy
metal called ghouls screamer
which is like a kind of a ghost rider
ripoff but with heavy metal bands and
stuff but he was here signing yesterday
and was designing for his sound for his
book he was signing his book but
everyone in the room was like that a
fantastic defense of course yeah but how
he Potter fans are quite intense some
are more intense and others and there
was one guy who was
there to kill Dan Fogler because and I
[ __ ] you not he was he believed that Dan
Fogler was actually the wizard grimwald
using a Polyjuice potion and his mission
to strangle him kill him to death this
got out amongst the line because your
Harry Potter fans you know they look
after their own they know when there's
an issue and so a few of the security
guards got to hear about this guy and
Tony Lee one of the guys who runs the
show
he kind of walked by and said so what
are you doing here I'm here to kill Dan
says he's Dan phobics not Dan Fogler
he's grim walls Polyjuice potion and so
Tony very carefully and kindly talked in
flew what he can't be because that
character is from the early part of the
20th century so he wouldn't be around
here anymore what he could have used a
time Turner no they don't work like that
do they they go back the other way oh
right a little away you're right they
don't worry we go think about the movie
Tony she's taken his wand very well you
did another one who's just gonna use his
strangulation that can I think so this
should talk through and eventually the
guy goes oh I suppose this guy can't be
he must be a relation of the character
from the film oh I suppose so oh I'll go
I'll go I'll go go and find Benedict
Cumberbatch then and he did at which
point he'd left the line and secured in
you and he was escorted away and dealt
with however you deal with people who
want to come on stage and kill Dementors
right yeah there we go that is a real
[ __ ] story yeah he'll never like
thank God we got him out of our line and
then to Benedict Cumberbatch his line I
mean similar happened to me I was at my
table because I set me up at the table
here it's great have a table it's
fantastic and a guy came up when I
wasn't there because I was out you know
trying to find stories and he spoke to
the guy who was next to the table say
where's rich Johnston I want to talk to
which Johnston no he's not here he'll be
back later
oh I owe what do you comics oh it's all
tumblr art I hate Tumblr art what's
what's all this stuff about do you know
Garth Ennis the guy goes I've heard of
Garth Ennis he's there can we book
variety created preacher amongst many
other things oh I hate Garth Ennis got
his ass
I said to the letter bomb it works I
sent him a letter bomb but I must have
got the stamps are the posters on it
incorrect because it was sent back to me
but uh I forgot it I sent it
and so I I opened it and it blew up in
my face and that's why I wear this this
flat cap this cap okay this is I'm off
now goodbye is like yeah so obviously
because he could have been absolutely
naughty could have been insane but these
days you don't know laughter mysteries
comic-con you don't know so you know the
words got back so Garth Ennis is aware
and he's checking his mail but it's at
least we have a kind of a community
where people are aware that some people
take it a bit too far and they can you
know they can report to the right people
salute so the word gets out there so can
I look after my own in that way when you
think about it like for a community that
carries around swords there aren't a lot
of bad things that happen that could
happen there was another show here in
London a couple years ago called the MCM
and they use they now have the whole of
the building that they're in but they
used to share it with other other events
going on and there was one I
specifically remember where there was a
meeting of it's a peaceful meeting of
Islamic this Islamic communities so
Sunnis Shiites Sufi all kind of meeting
together to find their common grounds
that kind of thing
so obviously when you get any kind of
community of peace someone's going to
get stabbed there was a stabbing and all
the police were like cordoning off
everywhere and there are these guys
walking past
well these [ __ ] off huge Japanese sword
things these massive things and they
weren't the ones getting stopped because
everybody else was getting so we're all
getting searched but yeah so you know
it's usually the comic book people are
generally the kind of people you can
trust
although you know the Phoenix guy that
has kind of ruined it for a lot of
people you know that's nice good know a
guy at the Phoenix Comic Con and
security security was tight it was the
time after we have the the Manchester
incidents and the bombings security was
tight but one guy got through security
armed to the teeth
he was cosplaying as The Punisher and
they let him flew with
hopper guns I'm over luck the lot and he
he got though he he then sent a few
messages to a few fans on Facebook
saying I'm going to kill Jason David
Frank the Power Ranger who wants to kill
a Power Ranger he was going to kill him
and then take out any other police who
were there at the same time Thank You
Kevin it's very kind of you and
thankfully the person he messaged on
Facebook goes dude this is insane you're
crazy I'm going to call the cops and
they called the cops you called the cops
on him and he was stopped I think a one
flaw way you're going up to a distant
even flank shooting him and then
shooting any police who came from him
and you know getting getting done in by
a hail of bullets so he's he's now being
arrested but yeah so after that moment
that was the thing they don't tell you
this year before you come to the car at
that moment there's been a lot more
security and suddenly all the metal
detectors are weapon and if you trying
to get your show so don't if you had
this you may have been searched quite a
bit but that's now that's now the norm
this kind of sting it just they were
doing a second base with me that was a
search and was like yeah Thank You
London this is a friendly town using the
whole fist duck eye those Potter fan
those powder fans you don't think of
them as being that intense
no cuts man if you're sitting there like
going if you're bringing Polyjuice
potion into the equation
absolutely like it's insane but I kind
of respect that like you committing your
logic that makes sense even if it's
twisted I'm wrong the I'm gonna name
drop right here watch this unzip my name
dropping dick alan rickman
the great alan rickman once told me a
story thank you the great alan rickman
once told me his story we were i was
doing a show here at the Oh two years
ago and he went to the show and he loved
to go to the shows the Q&A is the back
whenever I did in town he'd go we were
driving back and he's like I love going
to your q and A's everybody in the
audience knows who I am
he's like and they're all very polite
this is before the age of the digital
phone and selfie and stuff like that so
he likes being around people because
they just be like good on you and [ __ ]
like that so we're driving back from the
show and he wanted to grab something to
eat him and Rima is lady and my wife was
with me Jen and so would you have him
back from the o2 into London and he goes
I just want you to know her Bolton
apartment I can't [ __ ] do his voice
he goes I just want you to know I bought
an apartment in New York
I said get out of here after all this
time because he directed plays over
there and didn't commit to an apartment
and been in plays rather and didn't
commit to an apartment so he said I did
I bought a apartment and he gave me the
address and I was like holy [ __ ] man as
Tony dress is real great and he goes
well the problem is Rafe Eames lives in
the building as well and I was like why
is that a problem you guys are friends
and he goes yes but some of the potter
fans are rather intense and if they find
out that's that Voldemort and Snape live
in the same building he's like they
might bring it to the ground
I was just thinking about it very sweet
dude
that's his story what else you got well
just the story you just tell you that
ever mind me I was chatting to a
witchetty grants since I can name job as
well yeah I'm just the other the other
week and he was um talk about here we go
little ball like that but he was talking
about he he knows the fans they can't
the different fans he knows the person
who likes with mail and I and he knows
to personally like to Doctor Who and
it's the people who like Hudson Hawk are
the ones yes to run away from very very
quickly must not be that very they're
not Legion if this business know exactly
but you can tell them there's a certain
thing look at the are might hand you a
card he gets he's getting mistaken for
Geoffrey Rush he's in New York I would
believe that yeah well in America it's
about twenty years older than Richard so
which is not that happy about ever in
America we're all like they just look
British all together and so let's jump
to the audience man when we were in
comic-con we started throwing it out to
the crowd see what they want to talk
about what do you want to talk about
thank you it's a few days but thank you
in advance
since you're an honorary Canadian and
you like dick and fart jokes the king of
it have you watched leather kitty
I love letter Kenny it's a show it's on
what is it crackle in Canada I don't
know how you would watch it here but you
I guess they have an app you could
probably download it's hysterical very
Canadian show set in a very small town
where hockey and religion are the only
two things yes I've seen it I love it
Mallrats I took out as a series with
universal television and pitched it six
places of course the usual suspects
Amazon Netflix Hulu all of them were
like oh my god I loved Mallrats the
movie and none of them went for the
series there's still three places left
to go that we didn't pitch - one of
which was stars which is a channel in
those states I don't know if it carries
over here but they've been running a lot
of my flicks lately so we were like
maybe we should pop in there but in the
after the six places I felt really
[ __ ] burned not burned but it's tough
I couldn't play with my old toys like
clerks I couldn't do clerks three
because the guy who plays Randall didn't
want to do it the whole movie was
written for him and predicated on him so
once he was like I don't want to do it
it all falls apart so that's out of my
hands
Mallrats the series I don't own it
I don't know Mallrats cuz Universal does
so I had to kind of go through a weird
path with them and if that's frustrating
because I could have gotten it made
independently with outside money but
Universal doesn't let go of catalog
titles so that was frustrating pitching
at six places and watching just people
be like no I don't see it so then I was
like why am i beating my head against a
wall like I obviously want to play with
my old toys but I don't own some of them
they belong to other people but I do own
Jay and Silent Bob and have since the
beginning when we sold clerks to Mir max
I had this lawyer still have him john
schloss and i asked him hey i know i'm
gonna use those characters in another
movie like i already wrote him into this
movie called dogma i want to put them in
Mallrats like is there any way we can
maybe get like clearance or something so
that I can do that you know that Miramax
owens clerks but I can use Jay and
Silent Bob in the other movies and so my
lawyer was like let's just ask if we can
own them and I was like you can do that
he's like [ __ ] Hollywood we'll try
and so he was like hey talk to Harvey
Weinstein he was like hey you know Kevin
Smith wants to know if he can own keep
the Jay and Silent Bob characters from
clerks and Harvey was like who you know
and he was like Kevin Smith wants to
keep Jay and Silent Bob and he's like
who are they and he said they're the
drug dealers that hang out in front of
the store in the movie and he goes yz1
own the characters and he goes well the
one guy's name is Jay and the
character's name is Jay and he's afraid
that he won't own himself anymore or
something because these kids are from
Jersey man so but anyway they're looking
to have and Harvey goes well you know
the movies called clerks it's about the
clerk's nobody cares about the drug
dealers outside you know so yeah go
ahead and they gave us those characters
which we've owned ever since and has
been like a real umbrella and bad times
and [ __ ] even something as simple as
like us doing the podcast Jay and Silent
Bob get old would have been prohibited
because if we didn't own the characters
somebody else did so every time I run
into Harvey Weinstein he still kind of
reminds me of it to this day like how's
the Jay and Silent Bob Empire I was like
still thriving thanks to you egos worst
decision I ever made
does he relish being like the second
example after Fox and Star Wars of what
you should not do as a studio I think I
think Fox is crying harder than Harvey
ever did he's like I lost out on Jay and
Silent Bob or his Fox is like we had
Star Wars addendum to that yes
okay where do we go to next yes yeah oh
[ __ ] they got a mic in there pass it
around
oh the podcast last night and it
occurred to me and it might just be me
that Scott Mosier starts like a lot
Rick Grimes did me old man Rick
particularly yeah I saw him a night with
the full beard Scott who I do smart gets
with and produced all the early movies
he has the gas beard now he does have a
[ __ ] cosplaying Rick look about him
and stuff somebody came up to him he
said yesterday and he thought it was for
SModcast and they were just like I love
you on walking dead you know walked away
where we going to next oh yeah
just wondered are we ever gonna get
comic Macbeth comic book men over here I
hope so I don't know why it isn't I mean
it's in English so it should translate
pretty damn well and we keep asking AMC
and we're going into our season seven we
just started shooting the season 7
season the boys in back in Jersey are
shooting as we speak and when I leave
here I go to France with my mom and then
after we leave we go back to the States
we go to Jersey and shoot comic book men
so it's going into season seven I don't
know doesdoes AMC don't they have a
channel out here and they just don't put
it on that channel well that kind of
says a lot doesn't it I I don't know I
keep asking though but I'll ask once
again but I have no control over that
sort of thing
P&H questions in the front here hi Kevin
hey my name is patty and as well as
being a big fan of yours and I'm like
basically the biggest Harrison Ford fund
there is I want you to know I know you
got to visit the set of the force
awakens and cry do the Millennium Falcon
know a lot of stuff did you meet
Harrison have you met him have you got a
cool Harrison Ford story
I didn't mean Harris before he was there
when I was there on the set that day and
I saw him from a distance but I didn't
want to go over you know and be like oh
my god you know so I I saw him and I saw
Chewie from a distance but I didn't I
didn't go over and embrace and I've
never met Harrison Ford in any other
walk of life never come across him or
anything like that which sounds dirtier
than I meant to but net but I hear he's
my kind of people I hear he's a major
stoner from everybody that works in this
business they're like the only person
folks more weed than you as errors and
board you know I'm like are you [ __ ]
serious like oh yeah han Solo flies
mm-hmm but that's hearsay I don't
personally know that's me information
given to me by others but I've never met
the guy he did decide to get an earring
at 60 it's kind of metal yeah all right
nice questions from open the back here
jerk hey Kevin Hey serious question for
you now from high school we've had this
argument for years yes I sign a Bob
which one's the sidekick oh I gotta do I
answer it as the rider or is the guy who
plays one of them honestly it's silent
silent bob is the sidekick you lost yes
you see this Silent Bob's journey
I got a sucky stick now yopo
will come up here so we can all watch
[Laughter]
come on up there's a camera stuck I'll
pick it up soon nicely done Kevin yes
can I come and take a selfie with you
mark absolutely come on up I'll be
amazing all right where we're going next
so we have runner a team honors panel I
hope you've all enjoyed yourselves wait
what is that whoo yeah there you go
we have come to the end of the pattern
oh we are no [ __ ] that's one more
question I think your hand was the first
one I saw so oh my god you're gonna end
it no pressure all the pressures on you
the game is on your stick man here we go
and we basically put money towards your
video game that you're bringing out so
we're hoping have you got any more
details I actually do have an answer for
that because I asked Trevor cuz a few
people on Twitter were like hey what's
going on with the fig game they raised
their money on fig so I asked Trevor
what's going on with the game a lot of
people have been asking me and he said
that right now they're in they've just
built their character deck like they're
going to put up on the fig website their
update or something like that but he's
still like the game is at least a year
away but we've taken a giant step closer
but they're working on it tirelessly
that's all they do is that game and
stuff so I look forward to seeing it as
well what's going on just having a good
time let's do one more question that's
good though go you who looks like me
how weird is it to interact with people
who cosplay as me it is honestly it's
not weird at all like in one in one part
in order to become an entertainer
you have to believe that like anything
you have to say is a value to anybody in
the world every single thought you're
like I have to share that with people so
there's a degree of arrogance that comes
along with it so there's a part of my
brain when I see somebody dressed like
me that instantly goes now that guy's
got the right idea
but I've been seeing it for years like
Jay and Silent Bob Silent Bob
particularly was a very easy cosplay you
know you put on a trench coat backwards
baseball cap burn court beard if you
don't want to commit to like hair over
beard and so at cons I would see them
from I would say from the year 2000 till
about two years ago all I ever saw were
Silent Bob's and then about two years
ago it shifted and now I see more Kevin
Smith's like in jerseys and that Jersey
or in the black jersey and stuff like
that you're the rare one that doesn't
have a baseball cap on but you got a
lustrous head of hair so it's awesome
you look like TV Kevin Smith but he gets
his hair done and [ __ ] my mother's like
why can't you do that every day I was
like I ain't got the money but it's it's
it's wonderful like it's weird and
wonderful and and and the shift from
people playing cosplaying the character
that I played to like literally
cosplaying me makes me go like oh I've
achieved my goal of becoming a human
cartoon so it's a very easy look to pull
off but it's it's I love it it's there's
no part of it so it's creepy to me I'm
just like that rocks I always tend to
like get to take pictures of people all
the pictures I took with Silent Bob look
alikes they did you send me in stuff so
it's fun man my mother [ __ ] loves it
as I go tiger they look like you and I
was like that one's not even trying
let's do another you go before they
throw us out how is the house of going
he's asking about when I leave here I go
to New Jersey to shoot some comic book
men one of the things we're doing and
you're all invited if you feel like
taking the trip across the Atlantic is
on August 5th we're celebrating both my
40 on August 2nd is my 47th birthday but
we're celebrating on the show like three
days later at the same time celebrating
the 20th anniversary of Jay and Silent
Bob's secret stash we've been a brick
and mortar store for 20 years so we're
shooting an episode on bond okay
firstly we're shooting an episode there
of our TV show comic book men which we
can't get here for some reason
that focuses on that day and so what we
had was we called up the Guinness Book
of World Records and asked if we can get
them to come down and certify the record
we were trying to break we're trying to
break the record for the world's largest
gathering of Jay and Silent Bob
cosplayers so the like you just have to
break 250 that's the record and I was
like it happened before and they're like
no that's just a starting record for
anything 250 I was like oh it's gonna be
easy
so right now I think we're up to 500 so
they're 500 Jay and Silent Bob's well
I'll take a picture together and [ __ ]
like that and shoot that episode my wife
is coming out for the shooting of the
episode I was begging her to put up put
on a costume I was like just like Jay
and she's like I don't want to be
involved in your [ __ ] show but I told
her I was like hey man you got to be
careful because you're gonna be
surrounded by Kevin Smith and Silent Bob
look-alikes what if you accidentally
[ __ ] the wrong one of us and she goes
Kevin I don't even [ __ ] the right one
ladies and gentlemen I thank you for
being here today
thanks to our guests rich Johnston for
Fabian aback when I'm Kevin Smith I'm up
alone and tune in next week same
bat-time same bat-channel smart get back
on youtube.com slash Kevin Smith have a
great gone
[Applause]
you
[Music]